If our time with the SCP Foundation has taught
us anything, it’s that books are evil and
not to be trusted.
This is why, right now, you’re doing the
right thing and watching some nice, wholesome
YouTube videos rather than potentially exposing
your delicate mind to the devilry of the written
word.
Think we’re overexaggerating here?
Ha!
That’s how they get you!
Sure, you could pick up a book right now and
give it a read, but what if it was SCP-592,
the Inaccurate History Book?
Where just reading beyond a certain point
will drive you mad, and start to inflict potentially
deadly wounds caused by a nightmarish, retroactively
altered past.
Or what if you decided you wanted to read
some slightly more niche historical subjects,
and picked up a vintage copy of A Chronicle
of the Daevas, not knowing this is also An
Incomplete Chronicle, classified as SCP-140.
You get a paper cut on one of those aging,
yellow pages, and boom!
You’re suddenly forced into slavery in a
Daevite labor camp.
Maybe that rightly scared you off of history.
You want to do something a little more scientific,
so you grab a copy of SCP-1025, the Encyclopedia
of Common Diseases.
Next thing you know, agents of the CDC are
surrounding you, wearing hazmat suits and
setting up a secure quarantine tent because
they think you have a rare strain of Super-Mega-Ebola.
Not even some nice, escapist fantasy is safe.
You pick up a copy of SCP-1230, a Hero Is
Born, to have a magical fantasy adventure
in your dreams.
But then when you wake up, you’ve lost all
your lust for life because it just can’t
measure up to the fantasy.
And don’t even get us started on SCP-3512,
an anomalous book of pick-up artist tips called
“The More You Know: A Pick-Up Artist’s
Guide.”
Sure, it may have a forward by Snoop Dogg
himself, and it may be less dangerous to read
than the other books here, but considering
it’s ultimately a book of Fifthist rituals
designed to help you mind-control women for
romantic purposes, you’re probably a horrible
person if you want a copy.
So we’re all on the same page now: Books
are evil.
They’re best avoided at all costs.
And what is a catalog or magazine but a very
thin book, right?
So they’re Evil-Lite.
You cannot trust them under any circumstances.
That’s why, when Professor Snider got a
strange new magazine delivered directly into
his mailbox, it didn’t take long for him
to smell a rat and take it down to his local
SCP Foundation containment site for some preliminary
tests.
The magazine’s cover read, “The Official
SCP Sales Catalog.”
Already, this was weird enough.
The SCP Foundation doesn’t produce any kind
of sales catalog - that’s more Marshall,
Carter, and Dark’s modus operandi.
But this catalog had Dr. Jack Bright on the
cover, smiling and holding SCP-066 - The living
ball of yarn known as Eric’s Toy - like
he was overjoyed with it.
When Professor Snider showed the cover to
Dr. Bright himself, he said that it must just
be some high-quality photoshop, because he
never took a photo like that.
The cover also bore slogans like “Our best
issue ever!” and “Hundreds of bargains!”,
and Professor Snider soon found that both
of these bizarre slogans were true, in a manner
of speaking.
The inside of the catalog contained comprehensive
records of almost every SCP recorded on the
database, complete with photos and descriptions.
Though rather than the sterile scientific
depictions typical of an SCP Foundation document,
these descriptions were written like peppy
sales copy, aimed at selling off the “products”
in question.
Mortified by the potential security breach
he was holding, Professor Snider decided to
take a look through the catalog and assess
the damage, flicking between pages, both dazzled
and terrified by just how deep this thing
went…
ITEM #063 - “The World’s Greatest TothBrush”
Don’t let the typo fool you: this toothbrush
is out of this world!
No toothpaste needed, just gently scrub your
teeth and, like magic, all that nasty plaque
is completely obliterated!
And for those ground-in countertop stains,
look no further than The World’s Greatest
TothBrush!
Available in blue, pink, and green.
SCP-063, of course, being a toothbrush capable
of completely expunging matter from existence
with its anomalous bristles.
ITEM #123 - “Contained Miniature Black Hole”
Back in stock after so many requests, this
black hole is guaranteed to spaghettify anything
you throw at it.
Great for science projects and parties!
And what better way to say “I love you”
than with the gift of a contained miniature
black hole?
Order now while supplies last!
Warning: contains small parts.
It goes without saying why ever giving the
public access to a dangerous and unstable
contained black hole would be a disaster of
a truly cosmic magnitude.
ITEM#244 - “Ice Fog Jar”
Why waste electric-bill money on expensive
refrigerators?
This jar will turn an enclosed space of any
size into your own private meat-locker!
Freeze whatever you want: just pop off the
lid and watch it go!
Oh boy.
Engaging with SCP-244 is an extremely risky
business.
Once the fog from the jar has reduced the
ambient temperature of the room significantly,
it runs the risk of bringing in SCP-244-2,
a deadly gaseous entity that can kill people
with an instant flash-freezing effect.
ITEM #340 – “Insanity Candy”
A truly maddening prank!
Trick your friends into eating these covert
candies and watch them literally go out of
their minds!
Available in 5-packs.
Professor Snider winced at the memories this
one brought on.
SCP-340, now a kind of deadly virus, had once
been a particularly lethal packet of M&Ms
capable of inducing various types of severe
mental illness in its victims.
This was no prank, unless you happened to
be an extreme sadist with no regard for human
life and happiness - Like all the prank channels
that have since been wiped from YouTube.
ITEM #447 - “Ball of Green Slime”
What can you do with it?
What CAN’T you do with it?
Use it as a lubricant, top off your gas tank,
style your hair, or even dress up your salads
and sundaes!
The possibilities are endless!
Now available in blue.
WARNING: Do not apply to dead bodies.
Professor Snider gulped and shuddered.
The less said about that, the better.
ITEM #500- "Panacea"
Got Ebola?
HIV?
Cancer?
Athlete's Foot?
This pill cures 'em all!
No malady is too incurable.
OUT OF STOCK.
This one was equal parts relieving and surprising.
Relieving because at least this particularly
rare and powerful item was out of stock, and
when it was in stock, demanded a six-figure
payment per pill.
Surprised by the fact anyone outside the Foundation
knew about the Panacea and wasn’t bashing
down their doors to get it.
ITEM #551- “Impossible Puzzle”
Throw out your Rubik’s Cube and put down
that crossword!
This is the puzzle to end all puzzles!
No-one in history has ever completed it, can
YOU?
Hours of fun!
This mind-shattering jigsaw puzzle was an
incredibly dangerous thing to market as a
mere toy, especially considering some of its
victims lost their minds while attempting
to solve it.
But Professor Snider could only brace himself,
turning page after page, because things were
about to get a whole lot worse in the Official
SCP Sales Catalog.
ITEM#173 - “The Sculpture”
Spice up your living room with this unique
decoration!
The ultimate conversation piece that you will
literally never want to stop looking at!
Will draw the eye of all of your most distinguished
guests!
ITEM#035 - “The Possessive Mask”
For those with a theatrical spirit, this mask
is a perfect way to hide that ugly mug while
also putting some fascinating new ideas in
your head!
This mask really speaks to you, and you’ll
find that after wearing it for a while, you’ll
lose a lot of weight, too!
ITEM#1981 - “Ronald Reagan Cut Up While
Talking”
Are you a big fan of analog horror and are
one of the few people who still own a working
VCR?
Do you have a real disdain for the late ex-President
Ronald Reagan?
Then you’ll love this classic taping of
one of his iconic speeches.
No spoilers!
ITEM#5000 - “The Suit”
Are you looking for the latest word in anomalous
fashion that can be ostentatious or very,
very discrete?
You’ll love this total exclusion suit - It’ll
do everything you need and more, especially
when it feels like the world is going crazy
around you!
ITEM#055 - “The Anti-Meme”
It isn’t a sphere…
Uhhhhhhhhhhhh.
I’m sorry, what were we trying to sell you
here again?
ITEM#2000 - “Deus Ex Machina”
For when you or the entire world just needs
a fresh start, you can’t go wrong with this
unique big-ticket item!
Great for people who love mountain hikes,
too.
ITEM#914 - “The Clockworks”
Improve the people and possessions in your
life in fun and unexpected ways, or grind
them down into dust!
It’s all up to you, we don’t care what
you do with it as long as you pay for it!
ITEM#662 - “The Butler’s Hand Bell”
Just ring the bell and put your feet up.
Mr. Deeds, the world’s finest butler, will
do anything and everything you want (within
reason).
He’s well-dressed, polite, and endlessly
professional.
What more could you want?
ITEM#847 - “The Mannequin”
Looking for some customizable companionship,
fellas?
You’ll love the Mannequin.
Fully posable, she’ll change her features
based on your desire, and if you love the
Yandere types, you’ll love the fact she’ll
attack any woman who comes close to her!
ITEM#978 - “The Desire Camera”
Having a hard time figuring out what you really
want from life?
Having trouble finding out what your loved
ones want for their birthday?
Want to get some grade-A blackmail material
on someone in your life?
This is the product for you!
ITEM#1918 - “Tik Tak Tow”
Sick of video games?
Want something more intense and immersive
than even VR?
Want to give your kids a new playmate?
Then Tik Tak Tow is exactly what you need
- Set him up in your house, and the game will
never end!
ITEM#131 - “The Eye Pods”
These adorable little doodads make great friends
for your pets, and they’ll also keep a close
eye on your house when you’re not around.
They come in two colors and they’re sure
to lift up your mood just by being there!
ITEM#407 - “The Song of Genesis”
Are you a keen gardener who wants to grow
plants the likes of which humanity has never
seen?
This little cassette will turn your garden
into its own little slice of Eden in no time
flat.
NOTE: OUT OF STOCK DUE TO SUPPLY CHAIN TAMPERING.
ITEM#1370 - “Pesterbot”
A little toy with a big personality!
Perfect for any retro toy collector or kids
with aspirations to become evil geniuses.
Pesterbot is the ultimate hilarious playmate!
ITEM#348 - “A Gift for Dad”
Need a warm meal that’ll really soothe your
soul?
Forget standard hot plates, this plate will
give you a soup so delicious it’ll repair
your relationship with your dearly departed
father and give you the inner peace you’ve
been so desperately seeking!
ITEM#085 - “Hand Drawn Cassy”
The ideal gift for any art lover.
You won’t find a drawing more filled with
life than this one, and that’s a guarantee!
Let Cassy make a new home on your living room
wall!
ITEM#1609 - “The Remains of a Chair”
Once an extremely comfortable chair that would
appear behind you whenever you really need
to take the weight off of your feet.
Now discounted due to slight damages sustained
in transit.
ITEM#666 - “Spirit Lodge”
Got an addiction you need to kick?
Booze, pills, cigarettes, video games, YouTube
videos?
If you think rehab is too expensive and AA
is too condescending, then buy your very own
Spirit Lodge.
The perfect way to go cold turkey!
ITEM#323 - “Wendigo Skull”
Do you need to do some precious protein-loading
for your upcoming workout regimen?
Then this stylish piece of Algonquin headwear
will boost your appetite and make light work
of that new carnivorous diet!
ITEM#136 - “Naked Doll”
You’ve got to do the best to please her
just cause she’s a living doll.
That’s right, this product will have you
saying “Hello, Dolly!”
as she floats towards you in the nude.
She’s definitely going to provoke some strong
emotional reactions in you.
ITEM#261 - “Pan-Dimensional Vending Machine”
The perfect vending machine for your home
OR office if you like real surprises!
Mind-blowing (and sometimes head-exploding)
snacks, drinks, and treats from all over the
multi-verse come out of this handy-dandy little
machine!
NOTE: YOU ARE LIABLE FOR CHECKING ALLERGY
INFORMATION.
ITEM#2295 - “The Bear with a Heart of Patchwork”
If you don’t have health insurance, this
little bear can be a genuine life saver!
Skip those annoying organ donation waiting
lists and get right down to business with
this patchwork pal.
ITEM#426 - “I Am A Toaster”
I am an excellent four-slice toaster with
user-friendly settings and energy efficiency
that makes me both more affordable to use
and more environmentally friendly.
You will appreciate having me in your kitchen.
ITEM#1123 - “Atrocity Skull”
Are you a big fan of the darker side of history,
but find that photos, books, and archival
footage aren’t enough for you?
This tasteful knickknack will help you get
in touch with living history like never before!
ITEM#2430 - “Immortal Hitler Clone”
If you’re Jewish, Romani, Gay, Transgender,
Disabled, Polish, French, Russian, Mentally
Ill, or just not a terrible person, then the
Immortal Hitler Clone will make the perfect
stress-reducing punching bag for you!
ITEM#387 - “Living Lego”
Everything is awesome when you’ve got your
hands on the Living Lego!
The only building block toy that can play
back!
And they’re completely harmless unless you
step on them!
ITEM#137 - “A Real Toy”
If you are a toy collector or a kid who doesn’t
have many friends, then A Real Toy will enhance
any and every playing experience!
See your games come to life like never before.
Nothing beats playing with A Real Toy!
ITEM#272 - “An Old Iron Nail”
Want to keep something in place with zero
risk of escape?
As long as it has a shadow, then the Old Iron
Nail has got you covered.
Even has an in-built security system to keep
itself safe from any attempts to damage it!
ITEM#4158 - “Big Charlie”
If you love to grill, then you’ll love Big
Charlie!
This mighty steer will keep you swimming in
steaks forever.
Perfect for hosting barbecues for literally
everyone you know and everyone they know!
ITEM#3108 - “The Nerfing Gun”
Are other people’s things nicer than yours?
That ain’t right!
Get your hands on the Nerfing gun and knock
those jerks down a peg for good!
Professor Snider couldn’t believe what he
was reading.
This was textbook anomalous insanity; it even
had hard-cover copies of all the books we
were complaining about during the intro.
It didn’t take long for the Official SCP
Sales Catalog to be designated an anomaly
itself, with the number SCP-000-J. But if
you can believe it, the madness didn’t even
stop there.
You see, the catalog didn’t just contain
the anomalies themselves as available products,
it also contained a wide variety of SCP Foundation
merchandise: t-shirts, books, DVDs, even video
games and action figures, and so much more.
Naturally, none of this had ever been authorized
by the SCP Foundation itself, or the staff
or anomalies in question.
To give you an idea of just how absurd this
gets, here are some examples of the fresh
SCP Foundation merch inside the sales catalog.
There was a white cotton t-shirt with a slogan
on it reading “I Survived The Wrath of SCP-682”,
along with a picture of SCP-682 on the shirt
itself.
Available in size S-XXXL.
A 30.48cm, or 12 inch, SCP-076-2 action figure,
with interchangeable wardrobe, accessories,
and carrying case shaped like SCP-076-1.
When the real Able was shown a picture of
this action figure, he responded to it with
disgust, claiming it was an insult.
Though to be fair, Able does think that about
a lot of things.
A 2-disc CD titled “Dr. Clef’s Holiday
Hits”.
Cover depicts Dr. Alto Clef in a Santa outfit
and holding a microphone.
When he was questioned about it, Dr. Clef
denied ever recording such an album - He had
only ever recorded a brief ukulele LP with
no vocals back in 1991.
There was also a somewhat tasteless women’s
pinup calendar called “The Girls of SCP”,
featuring-- You know what, no, this one is
just creepy.
Moving on.
There was a 3-disc DVD set entitled 'SCP Brawl:
The Greatest SCP vs. SCP Fights'.
The cover depicts SCPs 076-2, 173, and 682.
Each disc is 9 hours long and features various
Keter level SCPs fighting each other.
We’ve actually been releasing segments of
it on this channel for months now, and we
intend to keep doing it, no matter how many
cease and desist letters we keep getting from
the Official SCP Sales Catalog.
There was also the two-disc soundtrack for
“FERNAND!
The Musical!”, a musical about the life
of SCP-082, which seems to contain some tracks
with the vocals of SCP-082 himself.
When asked about this, SCP-082 spoke with
great pride about his time in musical theater,
but given that he’s a pathological liar,
it’s difficult to know whether this is true.
He’s the current owner of the album because
he ate the last owner and refuses to give
it back.
Oh, and there was also an adorable, high-quality
SCP-999 plushie.
Incidentally, this is the only one of these
products you can get in real life, from www.scpswag.com.
No, we’re not kidding, check out the link
in the description after the video.
This whole anomaly ended up being a deeply
bizarre mystery for members of SCP Foundation
personnel to investigate.
While you could, theoretically, order multiple
iterations of each item, you would only get
the one real one, surrounded by a number of
cheap copies.
When Professor Snider called the helpline
directly, he was repeatedly rebuffed, with
the call operator hanging up on him if he
tried to do anything other than order an item.
If you do order an item, it will simply end
up on your doorstep, and then the Foundation
will need to come and recontain it.
Personnel wishing to test this item are required
to do so using their personal funds, as it’s
essentially just throwing Foundation money
into a furnace.
There currently only seems to be one of these
catalogs, but if ever one appears elsewhere,
it’s likely to give the SCP Foundation a
major headache.
See?
What did we tell you?
Books, you just can’t trust them.
Do you want our advice?
Just stick to YouTube videos.
In fact…
You should go check out “Why Everyone Wants
to Eat this Corpse - SCP-1176” and “SCP-049
- Boiled, Scrambled and Fried - Plague Doctor
Tale” for more bizarre and hilarious journeys
into SCP Foundation lore!